hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
there is a property crash
coming there is here's the thing okay
i'm just gonna level with you because
you'll see these prophets speaking out
and saying there's a crash coming or
this is gonna happen
and there'll always be right
because there's a crash that happens
around about every 10 years
there's no big deal property prices go
up and they go down and they go up
and they go down so you might have heard
these videos people talking like they're
prophets
there's a crash coming it's like of
course there is dick
because there's i mean you keep saying
there's a crash there's a crash there's
a crash there's a crash there's a crash
you keep saying that for years and years
and years and eventually you're going to
be right because
what happens in every if you go back the
last thousand years you go back the last
2 000 years as far as we can possibly
trace
we can see what happens is there's a
crash followed by a boom
followed by a crash followed by a boom
now here's the interesting thing
people say what are house prices going
to do
in the uk that is a dumb question
because house prices in the uk don't
follow each other
and what i mean by that is there's if
you look at london
london's going up does that mean that
manchester's going up at the same time
no you could get a massive boom in
london
and nothing happening in manchester and
then you could have a massive crash in
london on a massive boom in manchester
so there's always crashes happening and
there's always booms happening
so if you wanna if you wanna maximize
off of
property or any investment when you buy
is you buy
when properties have just had a crash
and you do that and then what's gonna
happen is it's gonna go up again
i mean right now you know there's things
not just properties but
investments in general if things you can
look at the stock market you can look at
business you can look at gold you can
look at anything
and the time to buy is not when there's
been a massive massive big
boom the time to buy is during and just
after a crash
however with property i don't like to
speculate too much and this is why
because
capital appreciation does not pay
my bills what i mean by that is
i've got properties that i've bought and
they've gone up really high and it's
fantastic and guess how i feel i feel
great
but it doesn't actually help me unless
i'm gonna refinance it and borrow
against that property or sell the
property
here's what i care about more than
anything i care about cash
flow cash flow so
and here's the very interesting thing
when there's a crash
within the property market and prices go
down
normally that's because of a recession
normally people are struggling
and there's usually three reasons why a
recession comes it's because the
people run out of money it's because the
banks run out of money
or it's because of fear usually fear of
one of the above so
when people are running out of money and
the banks are running out of money and
not lending and there's fear
what happens is people stop buying
people stop being able to afford to buy
and property prices start going down
generally but when that happens
people then start renting more because
they can't buy
and when people are renting more supply
and demand
it means if there's more demand of
people wanting to rent
rents go up so we saw this in the 2008
crash
massive crash but what happened to rents
well rents actually went up
so you when you're buying properties
don't get
too worried about the rabbit hole of
what's going to happen
to property prices people always ask me
what's going to happen i just
i just had someone messaged me about 20
minutes ago what's going to happen to
the market
well firstly it depends what market
you're in because every city has got its
own
economy you've got to get that every
city
even every town has got its own economy
i've had
i've had properties whereby i mean i've
had flats in warsaw
warsaw center and then i've had houses
in block switch
two miles down the road two miles down
the road
the houses two miles down the road have
doubled in value
over the last 10 years the flats in
warsaw
have gone down two miles away so if i
said to you this is what house brushes
are going to do this person
and this person could have both listened
to me and they'd have both had very
different results
just because of exactly where their
property is which is why you need to
study patterns which is why you need to
study what happened prior
and which is why you need to work out
what's the economy doing
in the area in the specific area where
you're wanting to invest
don't just don't listen to robert
kiyosaki on youtube
as much as i love robert kiyosaki but
talking about something very general in
america
and then you take it to your apartment
in warsaw city center
it's just stupid it's just it's like
listen
you need to think think for a minute
think about where you are
and and more than anything don't worry
about property prices going up or down
because what does it matter are you
buying the house
why are you buying the house in the
first place are you buying the house
because you want it to go up and then
you want to sell it
is that is that the strategy because
that's not my strategy and that's quite
a bad strategy
you should be buying the house because
of the cash flow that it gives you
you're buying a house for financial
independence you're buying the house and
what does financial independence mean it
means
that you've got a passive income you've
got a recurring income
which means that you don't have to be
reliant on a job so you're financially
free that's financial independence
and that does not come from a crash or
and a boom happening that comes from
cash flow and if you're buying a
property that's cash flowing positive
you could buy it for 100 grand and the
rent is 600
a month great fantastic the house could
drop down
to 50 grand does it affect your monthly
cash flow no
what about the house doubles in value
and goes to 200 000 pounds does it
actually affect your monthly cash flow
nope
so don't stress about what's gonna
happen what's gonna happen just make
sure that when you're buying
you're buying for cash flow and if you
if you do want to get capital
appreciation
don't go to listen to someone like
robert kiyosaki and say
what's going to happen to property
prices because because
property prices every city in every
country
has its own economy that's my two
pennies
i'd love to know what you think though
so is there going to be a crash yes
there is
is there going to be a boom yes there is
and it's your job to figure out what's
going to happen in the city
that you're investing in and it's your
job to make sure that you cash flow
positive
and make sure that you're getting a good
roi towards your financial independence
if this is so simple to me i don't know
what the big deal is
there's gonna be a crash there's a crash
every 10 years or so
like come on what are your thoughts
comment your thoughts below i'd love to
know them if you want to do some more
training with me as well i am going to
be running some webinars
teaching on the best types of deals to
buy and you can check check
the details on that in the description
don't forget to subscribe you can
subscribe
right about here and if you want to see
success students people that are
actually making money and be inspired
check them out right here and also
there's a video just for you up here
thanks so much see you next time comment
below